[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend wer
auch immer in Brüssel sich den Namen
ausgedacht hat aber fit for fifty five
klingt doch eher nach einem
selbstoptimierenden Diät oder
Workout-Programm für mit 50er als nach
einem klimapolitischen Projekt mit
Weltbedeutung fit for fifty five bzw im
EU kurz sprechen FF 5 oder 55 gehört zum
sogenannten green Deal ein Titel unter
dem man immerhin sofort erkennt worum es
geht Europas klimaschutzpläne mit dem
Gesetzespaket FF 55 sollen die CO2
Emissionen europaweit bis 2030 um 55%
gegenüber 1990 gesenkt werden daher die
Zahl 55
ehrgeizige Pläne die vom Europaparlament
heute in weiten Teilen abgesegnet wurden
es geht um viel und es wird folgen haben
für jeden einzelnen
Stahlproduktion ThyssenKrupp in Duisburg
ein Ort deutscher Industriegeschichte
hier haben sie am Wirtschaftswunder
gearbeitet den Strukturwandel erlitten
und hier stehen Sie vor einer weiteren
Revolution
wir können mal alle davon ausgehen dass
in 20 Jahren die Stahlindustrie in
Europa ein anderes Bild hat als sie das
heute hat Bernhard Osburg muss diese
Revolution organisieren viele hunderte
Millionen Euro wird ThyssenKrupp
investieren mit vielen hunderten
Millionen hilft der Staat die Zukunft
gibt es bisher nur als Modell ein
Hochofen der Stahl mit erneuerbaren
Energien produzieren Ausbau der
regenerativen Energie ist absolut
erfolgskritisch und deswegen muss er
auch
mit einem völlig anderen Tempo hier in
Deutschland vorangetrieben werden als
das in den letzten Jahren der Fall war
und so will die EU die grüne Revolution
hinbekommen betroffen sind alle
Wirtschaftsbereiche Verkehr Strom
Schwerindustrie die Industrie muss
Verschmutzungsrechte sogenannte
Zertifikate erwerben um CO2 ausstoßen zu
dürfen jedes Jahr gibt es weniger
Zertifikate zu kaufen deshalb kosten sie
mehr so wird der CO2-Ausstoß für die
Industrie teurer und sie wird mehr in
Erneuerbare Energien investieren
außerdem bekommt die Industrie
staatliche Förderung das Geld kommt aus
dem Verkauf der Verschmutzungsrechte
wir reden über ca 700 Milliarden Euro
dieses Geld muss zielgerichtet an die
Industrie und an die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zurückgegeben werden damit sie
die erneuerbaren Energien und
Energieeffizienz umsetzen können
Europas klimaplan ist eine Revolution
die viele hundert Milliarden Euro
verschlingen wird die Mehrheit der
EU-Abgeordneten glaubt so die Zukunft
Europas zu sichern
die USA und China die haben Milliarden
Programme um genau dort rein zu
investieren in die erneuerbaren Energien
in die klimaneutrale Stahlerzeugung und
da müssen wir auch hinkommen das heißt
wenn wir das nicht tun dann bleiben wir
auch in diesem wirtschaftlichen Rennen
zurück und das können wir uns auch nicht
leisten
am Ende gehen die Finger im Parlament
hoch Europas Energiewende ist
verabschiedet die EU leitet eine
Industrie Revolution ein und nicht nur
bei ThyssenKrupp hoffen sie dass alles
gut geht
nochmal nachgefragt bei unserem Denken
wenn man sich die Pläne ansieht dann ist
natürlich klar wer künftig nicht Klima
freundlicher produzierte oder konsumiert
für den wird es teurer zum Beispiel für
private auch beim Heizen das wird sich
ja nicht jeder gleichermaßen leisten
können
nein das wird sich nicht jeder leisten
können da wird es Leute geben die
staatliche Hilfe brauchen und die soll
es auch geben man muss sich einfach
vorstellen dass diese Reform wirklich
alle Bereiche des Lebens umfasst und
auch verändern wird die Art und Weise
wie wir essen wie wir trinken wie wir
uns fortbewegen und eben auch wie wir
heizen und an der Diskussion heizen hat
man ja festgestellt dass gerade beim
Thema Wärmepumpe es viel teurer wird und
eben viele nicht mitkommen und sich das
nicht leisten können das Geld für die
sozialen Hilfen die gegeben werden
sollen sollen eben aus dem Verkauf eben
von diesen Verschmutzungsrechten von
diesen sogenannten Zertifikaten kommen
das Geld von den Zertifikaten verkauft
geht an die Staaten und diese Staaten
sollen das dann ein Teil wieder an seine
Bürger weitergeben vor allem an die die
eben bedürftig sind und sich diese
ökologische Transformation nicht leisten
können das ist die Theorie man hofft
dass das auch wirklich funktioniert aber
wie gesagt bei so großen Reform
Revolution weiß man nie ganz genau ob es
am Ende klappt also es ist eine Reform
mit einer Wette auf die Zukunft
Dankeschön für diese zusätzlichen
Erläuterungen eine der großen
Problembereiche beim Klimaschutz für die
Europäer bleibt natürlich der Verkehr
während vor allem Deutschland noch am
Verbrenner hängt hat sich China längst
voll und ganz der E-Mobilität
verschrieben die chinesischen Hersteller
haben das Verbrenner Zeitalter
gewissermaßen übersprungen das wird auch
auf der großen Automesse in Shanghai
gerade sehr deutlich und das hat
Auswirkungen auf die deutsche
Automobilindustrie dazu gleich noch ein
Gespräch doch zunächst berichtet
Elisabeth Schmidt aus Shanghai die
kleinen feinen Unterschiede zwischen
chinesischen und deutschen Kunden
wünschen sind auf der Auto Shanghai
nicht nur an der riesigen rosa Schleife
sichtbar oder der Überraschung im
Kofferraum oder der einstündigen
Neuwagen Übergabe Zeremonie der
chinesische durchschnittsfahrzeugkäufer
ist deutlich jünger als der deutsche
passend dazu nennt Hersteller Nino seine
Kunden User das Elektroauto es ist ein
Lifestyle Produkt erweitertes zu Hause
ein Ort für Videokonferenzen viele
Innovationen rund ums E-Auto kommen
mittlerweile aus China
ich denke wir haben einen
Industriestandard in Sachen Intelligenz
gesetzt sowohl in Bezug auf autonomes
fahren als auch auf intelligente
Cockpits und unsere Rechenleistung ist
jetzt die stärkste der Welt für
Serienfahrzeuge
die deutschen Autobauer fahren auf dem
rasant wachsenden e-automat in China
hinterher die Marktanteile verschwinden
gering Volkswagen 2,4% BMW und Mercedes
nicht mal einen Prozent auf der Auto
Shanghai überschlagen sie sich fast mit
ihrem werben um chinesische Kunden
and the most
so beliebten deutschen luxusverbrenner
werden in China ausgemustert in großen
Städten werden Benziner Neuzulassungen
sogar versteigert für Tausende von Euro
die Zulassung von E-Fahrzeugen dagegen
fast umsonst und im Rennen um
Absatzzahlen tobt inzwischen auf chinas-
das ist auch deswegen ein Problem weil
die Chinesen sehr kostengünstig sein
können weil sie die ganze
Wertschöpfungskette besetzen das heißt
von den Rohstoffen über die
batteriefertigung bis zur Produktion von
Elektrofahrzeugen ist das weitgehend in
einer Hand während die Europäer auf
Zulieferer und auch im Moment ja auch
etwas instabile Lieferketten angewiesen
sind und damit auch teurer werden
viele Komponenten für deutsche
Elektroautos kommen aus China
Zollgebühren inklusive 2020 importierten
deutsche Hersteller fast ein Drittel
ihrer Lithium-Ionen-Batterien aus der
Volksrepublik außerdem stellt China fast
85% der weltweiten Dauermagneten her die
in Elektromotoren verbaut werden zuerst
einmal müssen wir auch unsere eigenen
Hausaufgaben machen in Europa in
Deutschland weit über die
Automobilindustrie hinaus
Kampfansage jetzt in Shanghai allein
volkswagen präsentiert auf der Automesse
20 eV Fahrzeuge Interview Anfragen von
ZDF und ARD lehnen alle deutschen
Autobauer ab bevorzugt werden
chinesische Influenza und die
Staatsmedien fast schon symbolisch für
die aktuelle Lage auf dem e-automat
Professor Stefan Bratzel ist uns
zugeschaltet Experte für
Automobilwirtschaft an der
Fachhochschule der Wirtschaft Bergisch
Gladbach guten Abend Herr Bratze
schönen guten Tag
ihr Interessen und Forschungsschwerpunkt
ist die Zukunft auch des Automobils was
haben Sie denn für einen Eindruck wenn
sie dann jetzt nach China auf die
Automesse in Shanghai schauen
ja China ist tatsächlich wie ein
Brennglas der Transformation der Branche
die Elektromobilität ist dort am
weitesten fortgeschritten
Digitalisierung spielt ein wichtigere
Rolle in China deutlich wichtiger als
bei uns und als nächstes Thema kommt das
Thema autonomes fahren also in China
sieht man ein Stück weit jetzt schon die
Zukunft und man sieht auch wer ja auch
in der Zukunft eine Chance hat und wer
Probleme bekommt das wird dann die Frage
auf welche Probleme die deutsche
Automobilindustrie da jetzt schon hat
oder noch weiter bekommt
ja ich meine wir sehen dass man eben mit
der deutschen Autoindustrie zu spät in
das Thema Elektromobilität eingestiegen
ist man hat das nicht so ernst genommen
am Anfang mein Tesla nicht ernst
genommen man hat anfangs auch die
Chinesen nicht ernst genommen und jetzt
ist man in einem Aufholprozess bei der
Elektromobilität und das zweite ganz
große Thema ist das vernetzte Fahrzeug
auch hier sind neue Kompetenzen zu
erlernen es müssen ja neue
Betriebssysteme entwickelt werden eine
ganz neue Fahrzeugarchitektur auch da
ist Tesla der Vorreiter und danach
kommen auch chinesische Hersteller also
es gibt sehr sehr viel zu tun und was
wir eben in China eben sehr stark sehen
dass jetzt plötzlich chinesische
Hersteller weltweit neue Wettbewerber in
der globalen Automobilindustrie sein
werden und das ist tatsächlich neu in
der Branche also mit ihren Autos dann
auch auf unsere Märkte drängen während
umgekehrt ist für die deutschen
Hersteller immer schwieriger wird noch
Marktanteile dort zu halten also VW ist
jetzt glaube ich erstmals nicht mehr
beim absatzmarktführer in China und bei
den
Elektroautos ist der Marktanteil der
Deutschen ja fast schon erschreckend
ja das ist genau richtig also das ist
jetzt das was auf die Branche hinzu
kommt man muss im Bereich
Elektromobilität eine viel größere
Dynamik entwickeln die Chinesen
chinesischen Autobauer und das zeigen
auch Untersuchungen der letzten Jahre
werden immer innovationsstärker und
kommen eben jetzt auch auf die
europäischen Märkte sind selbst schon in
Deutschland ja unter den Top Ten der
Innovation der stärksten absatzstärksten
elektromarken ist schon ein chinesischer
Hersteller mittlerweile also wenn wir
nicht aufpassen dann wird uns
tatsächlich in diesen neuen
Zukunftsfeldern die Mutter vom Brot
genommen und es ist eben jetzt nicht
mehr nur Tesla sondern es sind auch
Player aus China und sich das richtig
dass diese Autos auch eigentlich eine
andere Funktion haben also man hat das
seinem Bericht aus Shanghai auch gesehen
die die sind so eine Art Rollen des
Handy oder einen Rollen des Smartphone
also da werden ganz auch von den
Herstellern denke ich mir ganz andere
Fähigkeiten gefragt als von unseren
kfz-verbrenn er mit tormechanikern
ja das ist genau richtig die Fahrzeuge
werden künftig vernetzte Fahrzeuge sein
vernetzt mit dem Autofahrer vernetzt mit
der Außenwelt mit der Infrastruktur mit
lade Infrastruktur beispielsweise oder
den Ampeln und ganz wichtig ist im
Fahrzeug muss ein Ökosystem von
Dienstleistungen entwickelt werden ja
und wenn die Autos dann immer Autonummer
fahren das können wir jetzt ja schon
beobachten dann ist es eben möglich dass
der Kunde im Auto eben diese neuen
Infotainment Dienste die wir eben sehr
stark auch schon in China sehen kann
dann nutzen kann und das sind die neuen
Kompetenzen im Bereich Software im
Bereich Daten und Dienstleistungen die
die deutschen Autobauer schnell lernen
müssen nur mit Hardware mit Mechanik
konnte man jetzt nicht mehr weit das ist
im Prinzip
bekannt bei den deutschen Autobauern
aber jetzt geht es an die Umsetzung und
da muss man noch ein bisschen mehr
Dynamik entwickeln auch ein bisschen was
verschlafen sagt der Experte für
Automobilwirtschaft Stefan Bratzel ich
danke sehr für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
und dann geht es jetzt bei dir weiter
Heinz der richten sich der Blick auf die
Ereignisse in Duisburg heute abend na
bei einem Angriff in einem Fitnessstudio
in der Duisburger Altstadt am frühen
Abend sind laut zdf-informationen
mindestens vier Menschen verletzt worden
drei von ihnen schweben in Lebensgefahr
die Polizei spricht von mindestens einem
Täter der noch auf der Flucht sei
zahlreiche Einsatzkräfte sind vor Ort
das Gebietes weiträumig abgesperrt die
Verletzten seien in einen Krankenhaus
gebracht worden die Ermittler hätten das
Fitnessstudio durchsucht und gesichert
die Hintergründe sind noch unklar die
Polizei hat die Bevölkerung aufgefordert
den betreffenden Bereich und das Rathaus
in der Innenstadt zu meiden und bittet
um Zeugen Hinweise
und wenn es neu ist zur Situation dort
gibt informieren wir Sie im Laufe dieser
Sendung und dann auch in unserem heute
journal Update später
ein Untersuchungsbericht zum Umgang mit
Fällen sexualisierter Gewalt im
Erzbistum Freiburg wirft den früheren
Erzbischöfen Zollitsch und seiern
schweres Fehlverhalten und gravierende
Rechtsverstöße vor die Autoren des 600
seitenberichts halten solid der früher
auf Vorsitzende der Bischofskonferenz
war Versagen bis hin zum bewussten
verschleiern und vertuschen vor der
jetzige Erzbischof Burger zeigte sich
erschüttert im Erzbistum Freiburg wird
nach Angaben der aufarbeitungskommission
inzwischen von über 540 Betroffenen
ausgegangen und es gäbe über 250
Beschuldigte Kleriker
israel hat am nationalen Gedenktag JOM
haschua der sechs Millionen jüdischen
Opfer der Nationalsozialisten gedacht
landesweit holten am Vormittag zwei
Minuten lang die Sirenen
[Musik]
Passanten hielten inne in der
Gedenkstätte
Ministerpräsident nieder
in diesem Jahr wird besonders an den
Aufstand im Warschauer Ghetto gegen die
Deportation der Bewohner erinnert der
sich am Mittwoch zum 80
[Musik]
im Sudan gehen die Gefechte zwischen
Armee und einer verfeindeten Miliz laut
Medienberichten weiter trotz
vereinbarter Feuerpause die seit 18 Uhr
gelten sollte die Zahl der Todesopfer
seit Ausbruch der Unruhen hat sich nach
Angaben der Vereinten Nationen auf 270
erhöht am Samstag war der Machtkampf
zwischen den beiden mächtigsten
generellen des Landes eskaliert
Polen und die Ukraine haben ihren Streit
über den Transport von ukrainischem
Getreide beigelegt nach Beratungen von
Vertretern beider Länder sagte der
polnische Landwirtschaftsminister telus
ukrainisches Getreide dürfe wieder durch
Polen transportiert werden durch den
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine gibt
es mehr getreidetransporte auf dem
Landweg über die Nachbarstaaten was dort
zu Protesten von Bauern geführt hat
der wegen angeblicher Spionage in
Russland festgenommene US-Journalist
kirschkowitsch muss weiterhin in Haft
bleiben einen Antrag auf Hausarrest und
Zahlung einer Kaution lehnte das Gericht
ab der Korrespondent der US-Zeitung Wall
Street Journal war Ende März im Ural vom
russischen Geheimdienst FSB festgenommen
worden der Journalist und US-Vertreter
weisen die Spionage Vorwürfe zurück eine
Verurteilung drohen ihm bis zu 20 Jahre
Haft
die russische Organisation gulagonett
wurde von Menschenrechtsaktivisten einst
gegründet um Folterungen in russischen
Gefängnissen anzuprangern inzwischen
sammelt sie aber auch Dokumente über
russische Kriegsverbrechen in der
Ukraine und hat jetzt ein Video
veröffentlicht in dem ein mutmaßlich
ehemaliges Mitglied der Söldnergruppe
Wagner berichtet dass von ihnen in
bachmut auch Kinder gezielt getötet
wurden man habe von ganz oben den Befehl
gehabt niemanden davonkommen zu lassen
auch keine Zivilisten er selbst habe
einen fünf oder sechsjähriges Mädchen
erschossen
doch auch barbarische Verbrechen an der
Bevölkerung und massenhaftes Sterben von
Soldaten an der Front haben der
sogenannten russischen Winteroffensive
bislang nicht die landgewinne gebracht
die Moskau sich wohl erhofft hat
daran Hassan war für uns im Frontgebiet
im Süden der Ukraine in orthacke etwa 60
km von Odessa
vor dem Krieg ein beliebter Ferienort
seit Kriegsbeginn geht es um die
militärische Bedeutung der Kleinstadt am
Schwarzen Meer Soldat Roman ist im Ort
aufgewachsen seine Frau gerade schwanger
er verteidigt seine Heimat
vor einem Jahr waren wir nicht
vorbereitet aber entschlossen unsere
Stadt zu verteidigen jetzt sind wir
bestens vorbereitet und selbst zu
verteidigen es ist sehr schwer uns zu
attackieren nahezu unmöglich denke ich
vom Cliff oben sieht man die Landzunge
gegenüber sie gehört zur Krim dort vier
Kilometer entfernt sind russische
Stellungen
es ist unser Land unsere Ukraine die
geografischen Gegebenheiten sind kein
Problem für uns wir wissen wie wir sie
nutzen können damit der Feind sich
unwohl fühlt in seinen Stellungen und
weit weg will wir haben das bei der
Eroberung des Westufers in Hessen
demonstriert und jetzt bereiten wir uns
vor auch die andere Seite einzunehmen
auf der anderen der russisch besetzten
Seite besucht Präsident Putin seine
Truppen informiert sich über deren
Verteidigungsfähigkeit es sind Bilder
des russischen Staatsfernsehens wann und
wo sie aufgenommen wurden lässt sich
nicht überprüfen die angekündigte
Großoffensive werde kommen mehr gibt die
ukrainische Militärsprecherin humanjuk
nicht Preis den Feind Russland über das
Wann und Wo zu verwirren ist Teil der
Strategie die wenigen Menschen leben
hier schon lange in Reichweite der
russischen Artillerie seit Ankündigung
der große Offensive habe der Beschuss
zugenommen sagen sie du weißt das nicht
jeden Moment kann ein Geschoss
einschlagen meine Verwandten sind krank
mein Sohn ist dann der Freund wir
versuchen hier zu überleben
der Fischmarkt geschlossen die
Wohnblocks sind großen Teilen verlassen
ohne Krieg würde sich die Stadt jetzt
mit der april für die Sommersaison
rüsten man lebte hier vom Tourismus auch
von russischen Touristen
lebendig überall Menschen und Bewegung
es war so viel los sie kamen von überall
auch aus dem Ausland die Touristen
schwammen im Meer sogar drüben auf der
Landzunge und jetzt
die militärische Bedeutung von uschakis
war schon den generellen unter der
russischen Zarin Katharina der Großen
bekannt
bezeichnete Weise richtete sich der
Blick auch damals in Richtung
zurück nach Deutschland und zur
deutschen Bauwirtschaft der Herr
Stahlzeit eine ziemliche Flaute Heinz
die Zahl der Baugenehmigungen in
Deutschland ist nach neuen Zahlen der
Statistischen Bundesamtes auch im
Februar stark zurückgegangen dieser
Abwärtstrend geht nun schon seit Monaten
Frank Bethmann was lässt sich daraus
ablesen fürs Bauen und Wohnen
schauen sie droht sich weiter zu
verschärfen immer weniger Menschen
trauen sich noch eine Wohnung zu kaufen
oder ein Haus zu bauen weil sie sich
einfach nicht mehr leisten können die
neuesten Zahlen sind alarmierend in den
Monaten Januar und Februar brachen die
Genehmigung für Wohnungen in Neubauten
oder Bestandsgebäuden nochmals um über
23% ein überdurchschnittlich der
Rückgang bei Einfamilienhäusern
besonders drastisch das Nachlassen
Interesse bei Zweifamilienhäusern nun
entsteht nicht gleich mit jeder
Baugenehmigung auch ein Haus oder eine
Wohnung und doch signalisiert der
neuerliche Einbruch bei den
Baugenehmigungen vor allem eines das
Ziel der Bundesregierung und nach
jährlich 400.000 neue Wohnungen gebaut
werden sollen rückten immer weitere
Ferne damit aber wächst der Druck auf
den Wohnungsmarkt es gibt zu wenig
Wohnraum die Preise dürften daher weiter
steigen eine Entwicklung die längst auch
kleine Städte erfasst hat und die vor
allem immer häufiger Mieter zu spüren
bekommen
vielen Dank
Bahn und Flugreisende müssen sich wieder
auf Ausfälle und Verspätungen einstellen
die Gewerkschaft Verdi ruft für
Donnerstag und Freitag Beschäftigte in
der Luftsicherheit und Fluggastkontrolle
zum Streik auf und zwar in den Flughäfen
Düsseldorf Köln-Bonn und Hamburg laut
Medienberichten will auch die
eisenbahngewerkschaft EVG am Freitag
streiten
in Zürich ist das Skelett eines
Tyrannosaurus Rex für umgerechnet knapp
5 Millionen Euro versteigert worden
Trinity ist fast vier Meter hoch und
mehr als 11 Meter lang es besteht aus
den Knochen von drei verschiedenen
Exemplaren die zwischen 2008 und 2013 in
den Vereinigten Staaten entdeckt wurden
und 50% der Knochen sind
Originalmaterial über den Käufer ist
nichts bekannt der Handlung stritten die
Wissenschaft befürchtet dass der
Forschung durch einen Privatverkauf
Objekte von unschätzbarem Wert verloren
gehen
wenn Weltstars wie zum Beispiel
Hollywood Schauspieler oder Musiker über
ihre persönlichen Probleme und
Erkrankungen sprechen man kann das
Betroffenen helfen es kann Ihnen ein
Gefühl geben nicht alleine zu sein und
über Krankheiten sprechen zu können die
ist man manchmal vielleicht lieber nicht
spricht es kann helfen beim
enttarovisieren über die Themen zu reden
die für viele schwierig sind dass eine
Depression beispielsweise keine mentale
Schwäche ist sondern eine Erkrankung
diese Erkenntnis hat sich auch deshalb
langsam durchgesetzt weil prominente
ihre eigenen Patienten Geschichten
offenbar zuletzt tat das unter anderem
Popstar Ed Sheeran jung erfolgreich
scheinbar immer gut drauf doch hinter
den Kulissen sagen und sieht es in
seinem Leben oft anders aus Nicolette
feiert toll hat ihnen nach seinem
Konzert in Berlin getroffen
es ist schon eine Ereignis wenn sich ein
Weltstar wie Ed Sheeran mitten hinein
begibt in die Menge und dann singt ohne
Verstärker ganz bei sich
[Musik]
im Interview begegnet uns der Mensch
Erzieherin so offen spricht er darüber
wie er Musik macht in schweren Zeiten
du kannst Dinge in Lieder packen die du
nicht laut sagen kannst ohne dich zu
schämen ich habe das Gefühl es war schon
immer meine Art mich selbst zu
therapieren einfach die Lieder
aufzuschreiben wann immer ich mich
glücklich traurig wütend deprimiert oder
sonst wie gefühlt habe ich lass es raus
London 20 Februar 2022 ein tödlicher
Alkohol Kokain Mix Ed Sheeran verliert
seinen Freund Jamal etwas
über die Momente mit Jamal schreibt er
Sheeran diesen Song
[Musik]
wenn wir plötzlich jemanden verlieren
wollen wir das nicht wahrhaben es gibt
viele Phasen der Trauer das Leugnen ist
eine davon erst als ich die Schaufel in
der Hand hatte und die Erde auf das Grab
meines Freundes lebte wurde mir klar er
kommt nie wieder
Trauer ist nicht zu überlisten doch Ed
Sheeran wäre nicht Ed Sheeran wenn er
nicht daraus ein neues Album erschaffen
würde sein bisher intensivstes
ICE closed der dritte Song daraus seine
Offenbarung über sucht Tod und Angst
[Musik]
lange galt es als Tabu das Musikerinnen
sprechen über ihre seelischen Zustände
Lady Gaga tat es 2019
ich habe eine biologische chemische
Störung in meinem Körper die macht mich
depressiv ich muss dagegen Medikamente
nehmen
Billie eilish wird von ihren Fans dafür
gefeiert dass sie ihre Schwächen offen
zur Schau stellt
andere wie Avicii kam nicht mehr raus
aus dem Strudel
Erfolgsdruck ist ein Riesenproblem
schaffensdruck also man ist ja nicht
kreativ wann man will sondern da muss er
irgendwie alles passen natürlich ist
auch noch mal wichtig zu sagen dass der
Druck der empfunden wird und auch die
psychische Belastung häufig kompensiert
wird auch durch Konsum Drogenkonsum zu
Haus mentale Gesundheit ist ein riesen
Thema auf der ganzen Welt vor allem bei
Künstlern du musst es schaffen einen
kleinen Teil deines Gehirns zu öffnen um
die Gefühle in einen Song packen zu
können
erzählen macht gerade eine Therapie er
ist erwachsen geworden authentisch
mitten im Leben
[Musik]
beim Begriff pflegebedürftig denkt man
ja in erster Linie an Senioren doch auch
junge Menschen können pflegebedürftig
sein in Deutschland trifft das sogar
einige hunderttausend und ihr Schicksal
geht es gleich in der Reportage Reihe 37
Grad und um 0 Uhr meldet sich dann also
in Götte mir mit unserem heutigen Update
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eigentlich
herrscht deutschlandweit hoher Luftdruck
aber ein kleines Tief schmuggelt sich
aus dem Osten zu uns es ist ein
Höhentief und wird von ihrem Barometer
gar nicht angezeigt trotzdem bringt es
Schauer und einzelne Gewitter im Osten
im Süden sorgte für anhaltenden Regen
mit dichter Bewirkung und im Westen da
scheint längere Zeit die Sonne das ist
die Übersicht schauen uns die Details an
nach Südosten kommen viele Wolken auf
mit dem Tief und es regnet etwas nach
Norden hin klates auf und nach Südwesten
sind einige harmlose Wolken dabei die
Temperaturen sinken auf null Grad in der
norddeutschen Tiefe Ebene hier als
tiefswert und am mildesten ganz im
Westen bei acht Grad morgen also am Tag
Verlauf Aufzug von schau an einzelnen
Gewittern im Osten sonst aber im Süden
vor allem dicht bewölkt mit etwas Regen
nach
am besten hin scheint häufig die Sonne
unter Wind wird stramm aus nordöstlichen
Richtungen an der Ostsee mit Sturmböen
Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte bis fünf
Grad im Osten Deutschlands und 16 Grad
zum Beispiel am Niederrhein oder am
Oberrhein das ist dann der Höchstwert
die nächsten Tage am Donnerstag wird es
durchwachsen sein mit Schauern und
einzelnen Gewittern 5 bis 15 Grad ab
Freitag zeigt sich häufiger die Sonne
und es wird vor allem wärmer Samstag bis
20 Grad damit ein schöner Abend